hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play run vengeance
ok this is the sequel to the other game
and I don't exactly know what is
different other than that there was no
menu so here we go the street seems
wider and darker hit hey ok and I seem
to be a lot slower I will notice that
once again the sound is something that's
really cool and see these games oh hello
wait a minute this is another one of
those buildings I feel like this might
be a trap just off the cuff there just a
little bit of a thought um usually when
I went in this place before ok I'm gonna
run you know I don't hear anything
behind me like I did before but I'm
pretty sure I shall receive my vengeance
what OH
ah ah ah haha you yeah you got me good
on that one okay oh well let's see now
oh my now that I have you where I want
you you have no other choice but to
listen I'm going to put you in
situations that are going to scare the
crap out of you to survive you must find
the teleporters they have a red glow
though there is nothing to look forward
to when you find them I am going to
enjoy seeing you scream alright then
hi hello hi alright ha ha ha ha ah ha ha
alright we're no longer on this street I
guess this is under the premise that in
the last game he found you you didn't
run fast or far enough and you were got
so now I'm in a building of some sort
and I need to find teleporters for some
reason I don't know why but I would
rather find a great big glowing purple
gem if that's all right with you
alright okay alright okay okay okay
alright
oh just um start running now haha what
does this guy need to get vengeance for
did I steal his family jewels and
suddenly he feels the need to hound me
for the rest of my days
I'm gonna get lost in here there's so
many play not bad you found the way out
I'm sure I startled you a few times long
away no you didn't hah now for the next
one oh okay so this is how you're gonna
play it with me eh
wait a minute isn't this the building
that I was in before when I first came
in here
interesting hahaha
I either must have been incredibly lucky
or that was easier to find that I
thought because there were so many
twists and turns in that last level that
I don't know how I found it right away
I'm just too pro for this guy what
should I name him Jimmy Jimmy Jackson
Jeremiah Jimmy Jackson dodge Nikes hi
you're gonna hit me on a dead end I
swear I hear a little something out
there like the slightest sound but
nothing so far
like I said in the last game the sound
work is pretty good in this game like
the environmental sounds the ambiance
it's really good there's all these
subtle things that I swear I hear anyway
ah I must be so talented that one did
not have a single jump scare in it the
anticipation is what made you look away
most of time okay alright so you're
gonna explain the levels after you get
out of them that's the best way to have
a scary game alright
I mean he's not wrong but explicitly
stating that is kind of weird because it
is the ambience I was just commenting
the ambience ah
why hey what was that
I didn't be amigos I didn't leave again
leaving I didn't even get a chance to do
anything you like push me into that
place and this has no way out oh yeah it
was it there's no way out
wait I can't move oh oh oh oh oh haha
was I just stuck her what was the deal
with that ha ha ha I didn't make any
sense all right then so there's no way
out from here and I'm trapped in a room
of goopy redness that's what I like to
see whoa hi you found the way out you
can leave for now but I will be
summoning you for my revenge once again
who knows our next meeting could be much
sooner than expected what that was it
no way no I what that's bull honky aah
aah that was it what the hell
ha ha you kidding me aw I was so
disappointing it had so much potential
but it was so weird because it kept
going like this is how I scared to you
in the last level were you scared
I've enjoyed seeing you be scared I mean
it really broke the atmosphere with
those messages I wish those weren't
there like something a bit more subtle
please in the next game I mean it's
definitely an improvement because I mean
very varied levels different types of
things better ambience but at the same
time you broke everything at the same
time yeah had such potential but I would
not okay so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
caduceus I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
buh-bye
papi
knock on door
you
Kludd
I